day one of historic impeachment hearings
produced a very startling claim it
directly ties President Trump to the
effort to pressure Ukraine to
investigate former Vice President Joe
Biden and his son Hunter
the top US diplomat in Ukraine that's
Bill Taylor testified that a member of
his staff overheard a call between the
president and the ambassador to the
European Union that's Gordon Sandlin
Taylor says it's onlin told the staffer
the president cared more about
investigating the Biden's than about
Ukraine at the White House President
Trump said he knows nothing about that
phone call with Sunland and he called
the impeachment hearings a quote joke
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill where
she covered yesterday's first public
hearing Nancy good morning so are we
gonna hear directly from this staffer
yes he is based at the US Embassy in
Ukraine but he'll be here on Capitol
Hill tomorrow testifying behind closed
doors
his story appears to undercut the
Republican argument that there is little
direct evidence of the president's
intent what this call indicates as other
testimony has likewise indicated is that
the instructions are coming from the
President on down the new revelation
comes from a u.s. embassy staffer David
Holmes who was sitting at a Ukraine
restaurant with US ambassador to the EU
Gordon Sunland when sunland placed a
call to the president the member of my
staff could hear President Trump on the
phone asking ambassador Sandlin about
the investigations so your staff member
here's the president asking about the
investigations meeting burr yzma and the
Biden's in 2016 an ambassador somnolent
told President Trump that the Ukrainians
were ready to move forward he did the
story was relayed by the top US diplomat
in Ukraine bill Taylor who testified
that Sandland told him repeatedly that
mr. Trump would not release US aid to
Ukraine until that nation aggrieved to
investigate his campaign rival Joe Biden
he said that President Trump wanted
president Solinsky in a public box and
what did you understand that to mean to
put Solinsky in a public box I
understood that to mean that President
Trump through ambassador song
was asking for president Solinsky to
very publicly commit to these
investigations
it's a witch-hunt it's a hoax I'm too
busy to watch it President Trump was
asked about his phone call during a
joint press conference with the visiting
president of Turkey I know nothing about
that first time I've heard it
the one thing I've seen that Sandlin
said was that he did speak to me for a
brief moment and I said no quid pro quo
under any circumstances his press
secretary Stephanie Grisham also
responded on Twitter dismissing
yesterday's witnesses who are diplomatic
veterans as two bureaucrats with a
foreign policy gripe Republicans
insisted Taylor's information was
secondhand we got six people having four
conversations in one sentence and you
just told me this is where you got your
clear understanding and you're their
star witness let me just say that I
don't consider myself a star witness for
anything they do Democrats praise the
witnesses Republicans say they still
want to hear from the anonymous
whistleblower now there is one witness
one witness that they won't bring in
front of us they won't bring in front of
the American people that's the guy who
started it all I'd be glad to have the
person who started it all come in and
testify President Trump is welcome to
take a seat right there
the next public impeachment hearing
comes tomorrow it features Murray
Ivanovich the former US ambassador to
Ukraine who was smeared by the
president's personal lawyer and then
recalled to Washington earlier this year
ambassador Gordon Sandlin is one of
eight witnesses test scheduled to
testify publicly next week he'll be
grilled about why he had to change his
story after he was contradicted by so
many other witnesses all right Nancy
thank you very much